et là
[Musique]
C'est là
et là
votre notre travail est de renforcer la
coffre de patients dans le lit de tabira
se tenir debout avec sa démarche de travail
parce que parfois vous ne pouvez pas parce qu'ils
ils sont vraiment faibles
et là
C'est là
et ce n'est pas seulement le médecin que ce patient
J'ai besoin de précision infirmière pour
pansements et soins nutritionnels pour les
kinésithérapie de réhabilitation nutritionnelle et
l'orthophonie qui sont très importantes
psychologues et psychiatres pour soigner les
partie émotionnelle de ces patients qui est
assistante sociale très ébranlée
organiser le retour à la maison, non?
C'est là
et là